we need the death penalty for the same
reasons we have always needed the death
penalty there are some crimes for which
anything less it's just a travesty it's
time to look behind the curtain and see
what all of this is costing in
California taxpayers we often debate the
death penalty on moral grounds but this
November California voters will decide
the fate of the death penalty based on
its cost-effectiveness attorney Paula
Mitchell offered a study finding that
California's death penalty is too costly
and ineffective over the last 32 years
it's cost California taxpayers about
four billion dollars to have the death
penalty and over that period thirteen
executions have been carried out the
safe initiative would replace the death
penalty with life without possibility of
parole as a maximum punishment former
San Quentin death reward and Jeanie
Woodford has been the key advocate it
takes so many years for inmates to
exhaust their legal appeals and inmates
sit on death row while we spend millions
and millions of dollars on each of their
cases the massive expense is partly
because San Quentin itself is so massive
there are over 700 prisoners now on
death row making it the largest in the
country
California is responsible for housing 22
percent of all death row inmates in the
country and we've been responsible for
carrying out one percent of all of the
executions Mitchell says that the death
penalty costs 134 million dollars over
and above the cost of life without
possibility of parole because death row
inmates get special attention like
single cells and extra legal resources
for their never-ending appellate process
that means more attorneys more experts
they also have two trials instead of one
they have a guilt phase trial and a
punishment trial then they start their
direct appeal process which now takes
about ten years before the California
Supreme Court decides whether the
conviction should be affirmed or
reversed we need to speed up the review
process we are currently spending far
more than we need both in time and
resources reviewing claims that have
absolutely nothing to do with whether
the guy committed the murder or not
legal director of the criminal
justice Legal Foundation can shite ageru
says California should look to other
states to remodel the system in Virginia
they executed the DC sniper six years
after the crime now that's the case as
complex as they come one of the dangers
of of this idea that we should just
hurry up and speed things up is that it
could result in cases where someone who
is in guilty or who didn't have a fair
trial being executed all across the
United States they found many people on
death row who were actually innocent of
the crime then the last person who left
death row in 2011 as an exoneree had
been on death row in Texas for over 20
years so I think it's kind of a myth
that is quicker in other states overall
we wouldn't need to spend almost a
hundred million dollars more per year to
so call fix the system and we just don't
have those kinds of resources
Heidegger agrees that capital cases cost
more but says we need the death penalty
because life without parole just isn't
enough I don't think life without parole
is sufficient punishment we shouldn't be
letting people off easy based on some
kind of excuse making mechanism we
should hold people responsible for what
they choose to do without possibility of
parole is a very harsh punishment and
it's cheaper and it provides for public
safety because we have very secure
prisons and we have a California has a
really thorough classification system so
inmates are placed in the right custody
level so that they don't harm each other
or staff the cost of housing inmates for
life is still a huge expense but most
death row inmates are housed for just as
many years as those sentenced to life
without possibility of parole in that
same time period that 13 inmates were
executed over 80 have died of other
causes the average time on death row in
California is now approaching 30 years
so we have more inmates on death row who
have died by natural causes or by
suicide especially because there have
been no executions since 2006 the holdup
has been the arguably cruel and unusual
method of lethal injection and
bureaucratic hurdles have prevented any
sort of resolution and if and when this
is resolved it would take over a decade
to execute those currently on
throw we would have to carry out five
executions a month every month for the
next 12 years just to carry out the
sentences for everybody currently on
death row and in that mean time we would
have added another two to three hundred
prisoners to death row so that's
something that voters and taxpayers
should think about is this something
they want to see happen an execution
every few days
for the next ten years Watford says
there are far better ways to use these
resources if we're really concerned
about public safety we need to put money
in preventing these crimes keeping
police on the streets and solving
unsolved crimes and not spend our money
on the death penalty which is really
it's really a hollow promise for people
you get a lot more for your public
safety dollar if you can resolve some of
these homicide cases this measure does
divert funds thirty million dollars a
year for three years towards solving
crime and rape cases in even taking this
into account the total savings is still
estimated to be around one hundred and
fifty million per year we're only taking
a small portion of the savings for the
sole purpose of solving unsolved crimes
the hundred million dollar fund created
by this initiative is really a ploy to
try and get votes from people who would
not otherwise vote for it Heidegger has
questioned the initiatives legitimacy as
well as Mitchell's research the numbers
should be considered very very
skeptically I asked her to share her
data and calculations so that they could
be checked over and she refused her
email response says that her sources
facts and figures are all there and
publicly available there has been a
strategy that sort of worked over time
with voters and taxpayers to say we just
can't figure out how much it cost
there's no way to know we can't put a
price on justice basically sit down and
shut up don't look behind the curtain
there's no way to figure this out
California wants the death penalty we've
always wanted the death penalty this has
been their their strategy and it's it's
worked until now when everything in
California is on the chopping block and
the death penalty is no exception
Woodford is optimistic about safe
passing when they initially asked people
to sign there was some hesitancy but
when they gave them the cost
how much it was costing the state of
California and that when they understood
that life without possibility of parole
is a very real punishment then they
gladly signed our petition
[Music]